that's crazy have you met dave chappelle
yet i did
i met him that's a wild story so cause
for us that's our goat
yeah chappelle show in high school oh
bruh bruh untouchable
so that was that was crazy um
so i was going to like audition like the
talent director for the comedy store
would have me come in like
every so often like kind of like
audition to see like if i wanted to move
me up to like
the next step right right um and one
night i was going in there
and uh you know
i you know i was just rolling up and i
and i turned over
to my left and i see dave chappelle and
i was like oh [ __ ] he just walked right
up to me he was like what's up man
and i was like uh i was like i'm a
comedian and my first name is chappelle
[Laughter]
and he was like hell yeah
[Laughter]
he thought it was so cool right and uh
it's like you going up man i was like
yeah you know going to be and then
the talent director had walked up saw
both of us he goes
oh my god chappelle's and i was like
that's cool that's cool
but uh then um i was like
dave is it cool like if i get a picture
with you man
like i don't know yeah yeah because he
don't really do pictures or no i know i
i i know this
yeah so i was like can i get a picture
with you he was like
chappelle let's take a picture and i was
like damn
yeah i dj'd uh the after party
for that show in in phoenix okay the one
that he did in
2015 yes so he i went to that show
so he actually rented out my boys club
[ __ ] who's the dj he rolls with
trauma drama yeah so
my boy hits me who owns monarch in
downtown phoenix and he's like yo you
want to come and dj for de chapo and his
friends and this it was like a monday
night it was an off night it was weird
i was like what do you mean he's like
dude him and what's the uh
daniel and no but it was also the uh the
guy who does all the roasts was there
he was a dick jeff ross oh jeff that
dude was a straight [ __ ] oh he was
a big piece of [ __ ] i was like bro
there's like 25 people here i'm like hey
what's up man you're funny and he just
looked at me like i was crazy i was like
i will
go [ __ ] you sometimes you want to just
throw hands with people yeah but yeah no
but it was kind of it was crazy because
dave i was djing and i think he ended up
hopping on or he was just telling me to
play [ __ ]
and uh he was cool as [ __ ] man he took a
picture he was this is when he was swole
though
oh yeah when he swallowed he was jacked
and then he gave me his lighter
oh dale i forget how like uh
lit up we were a little bit blunt or
something
and then i want to give him his lighter
back and he's like just keep it
and the lighter had his logo on it and
this is the c
and and the lighter said chappelle's
lighter i still got it
oh you still got it yeah of course okay
dave chappelle gave me his lighter
yeah [ __ ] and then he took a picture
with me
so yeah but i felt so weird cause look
i'm the type of guy who i'll pass on the
picture
but i'm like man this is dave chappelle
i don't know if i'm ever gonna be around
this guy again
and i don't give a [ __ ] about rappers
and musicians but like dave chappelle
be like if i met larry david like i
don't care if larry david hates my guts
and i get on his nerves
wherever he's at if i see him
he could be enjoying a meal with
children
[Laughter]
i'm gonna be like hey dude can we get a
selfie
see i'm